I was standing on the corner of 68th
street lexington avenue right here in
Manhattan once and I approached a woman
and very elegant and I asked her to look
across the street and tell me if there
was a drug store on the corner she said
I'd be delighted and then took me by my
arm and led me across the street to the
drug store she was kind of surprised
when i went back and stood on the corner
and she came back and asked me why
wasn't going in the drugstore i said a
friend of mine told me that his office
is located at 168 street and lexington
avenue across the street from the
drugstore this woman was a guest but I
thanked her for taking her time out to
help me and told her it doesn't really
matter I applaud your service so thank
you very much
Oh some of you know her thank you very
much president Bollinger for that very
kind introduction I wish you were
president when I was at Columbia maybe I
would have gotten out sooner to all
those who are national chairs of service
nation those of you in the public and
private sector who have taken your time
and given it to this great cause i want
to thank you to Senator Barack Obama
Senator John McCain senator Hillary
Clinton Mayor Michael Brune Bloomberg
Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger and the
first lady Laura Bush among the leaders
will be speaking tonight I want to thank
them for taking their time out to be
here at Columbia at this great great
event I am honored to have been invited
to have attended the service nation
event and I want to welcome all of you
to New York we are very pleased to have
you here and want to enhance the service
of service nation in any way we can the
33rd governor of the state of New York
once said that he felt that the welfare
of each of us is dependent fundamentally
on the welfare of all of us that was
President Teddy Roosevelt years later
his fifth cousin another relatively
obscure governor of New York named
Franklin offered us that human kindness
does not in any way weaken the stamina
or soften the frag fabric of a free
people these two men were not bonded by
politics one was a Republican the other
a Democrat they were bonded slightly by
blood but they are linked inextricably
because of their service to human
dignity one does not have to be a
president to provide service it's just
that the Roosevelts were two links on a
long chain of citizens service that
Americans have demonstrated since 12,000
men offered the call answered the call
of the rule of the revolution and
offered their service against attacks by
the British and would be available
within a
it years later up to last year that has
been stretched to the point that 61
million Americans offered eight billion
hours of service in this country they
would help
they would help struggling students they
would deliver meals to seniors they
would help those in poverty among other
tasks indeed 26 premiere Americans took
time out from their deliberations to
offer service last year 23 million more
than did so 20 years ago right here in
New York three million people offered
366 million hours of service and so this
is a call that has been heated in this
country and one we badly need because
unfortunately three-quarters of our
society feel that our country is going
in the wrong direction perhaps they feel
this way because just this year 772 a
million seven hundred seventy-two
thousand Americans have lost their jobs
since last summer a million Americans
have lost their homes and so now is the
time for us to step up with our service
more than ever that is why today I am
elevating the director of our office for
national and community service right
here in New York State I am elevating
that office to a cabinet position in my
administration
thank you
thank you I thought you would like that
but now we come to a point where service
cannot just be a temporary plan but a
lifelong commitment and we're going to
be needing a president that believes in
this type of service and we are
certainly fortunate in this country that
both of the candidates major candidates
for president this year have performed
outstanding service to our communities
from Barack Obama who eschewed personal
opportunity and lucrative offers to work
in service organizations in the city of
Chicago Illinois to John McCain who
almost had to perform the ultimate
service when he found himself lingering
on life in a prisoner of war camp in
North Vietnam during his service to the
military of the United States both of
these men aptly follow in the footsteps
of the Roosevelts one of them will be
called upon by us to lead this nation
and I hope that they will find a
commitment to service perhaps funding
the Corporation for National community
service and signing legislation that
would add service as part of our
American tradition
finally I would add that today is
probably the seventh anniversary of the
greatest collective service this country
has ever seen when we were attacked by
terrorists in September 11 2001 and
people ran into buildings firefighters
EMS workers police officers and private
citizens to rescue people they didn't
know or never met when those who
survived were asked about it they said
that they just didn't think about their
ambition they didn't think about their
families they didn't think about their
other obligations they just knew that
they had to help someone Pope Gregory
the first known as st. Gregory the Great
always admonished Christians to love
their neighbors as they would love
themselves but he said that there are
moments of epiphany where a person will
feel a bond with one whom they've never
met pierre abelard writing in the 12th
century added to that by saying there
are moments of feelings of identic image
in which individuals because of an
intervening crisis tour start to see
others as being part of them and so I'm
hoping that perhaps that Christian adage
will take on a new meaning in the 21st
century as more of us are involved in
service as we come closer to that
oneness of the human spirit and we
actually re amplify the idea of helping
our neighbors as we would help ourselves
to helping our neighbors because they
are ourselves thank you very much